explosive developments tonight
surrounding andrew cuomo's burgeoning
sexual harassment scandal
as we are now learning the new york
state attorney general is reviewing a
letter from republican state senators
asking for a full investigation but in
all fairness this effort has all started
because of democrats not republicans in
the state of new york
and by the way this all because even
left-wing hollywood now is beginning to
turn
on the man that they gave their emmy to
and as the times
well group was for example released a
statement calling for a full-fledged
investigation
as they're reporting governor cuomo is
denying the allegations
ask yourself where are where's the
entire i believer
caucus where are the rest of the i
believers where is hillary clinton
kamala harris
kirsten gillibrand the ones that rushed
to judgment
and gave no due process to justice
kavanaugh
by the way who by the way get to say it
said this reportedly said
she hasn't even read the complaint
against cuomo
yeah of course the cuomo scandal is also
a media scandal
major networks have largely ignored both
the nursing home cover-up
and the sexual harassment allegations
look at fake news cnn
finally covered the cuomo allegations
for a mere 96 seconds
while totally ignoring it during the
prime time hours
but compare that to their endless
never-ending hysteria of unfounded
allegations against justice kavanaugh
and donald trump
every second minute hour of every day
look at these two headlines right there
on your screen
look at the one from september 2018.
woman
accuses kavanaugh of assault in letter
to senator
compare that to a headline from thursday
quote
cuomo denies former aids harassment
allegations
oh slight difference in coverage do you
see the abuse of
bias and don't forget you know a lot of
these fake news channels covered up
cuomo's nursing home scandal for months
and months
refusing to take it seriously despite
what was overwhelming evidence of
wrongdoing
and now they're continuing to downplay
what is
a growing harassment scandal with very
serious claims
fascinatingly it's democrats leading the
charge here with reaction
new york post columnist fox news
contributor miranda devine
and fox news contributor media columnist
for um
for the hill joe concha miranda you know
if you really look
there aren't even any
republicans that i can even name in new
york to be honest that have
any kind of real influence in new york
state not trying to be rude i'm just
being factual
but the point is you know you look at
this case this is largely democrats
going after cuomo they're the ones
calling for impeachment and censure and
investigations
yes well it is a one-party state and
anyone who's worked with andrew cuomo we
now discover knows what a bully he is
and
knows about his skeletons in his closet
it's just that they kept them
all hidden when he was useful to them
in terms of attacking donald trump and
of course he was used last
year and put himself forward as a foil
against donald trump as
what joe biden called the gold standard
in
leadership during the pandemic which of
course he was the opposite
he was a terrible leader during the
pandemic as we know
with the nursing home crisis and all
sorts of other disasters that have
happened under his reign which
are all under a cloud there are lots of
questions being asked about
the contributions the donations he
received from the nursing homes and the
hospital industry
and the fact is that if he were a
republican
governor you can bet that cnn and msnbc
and new york times and
all the uh democrat leaning media
would have made a absolute mountain out
of this story there would have been
hundreds and hundreds of stories by now
just as they were with justice kavanaugh
yeah and joe look you followed the media
for a living this isn't surprising this
is pretty much
every day uh every day of the year
every minute of every hour of every day
yet it's not surprising that that's the
shame of it all right john and who knew
that cnn
stood for the cuomo news network because
how else do you explain the bias of
mission
around a story that has so many layers
and has such
legs to it every day there's a new
development that we're learning about
and you have layer one for example and
this goes back to
last march right when the governor
signed that order to pakova 19 positive
patients
back into nursing homes then you have
layer two where you have a senior aide
and melissa
derosa she said this recently about the
nursing home death tallies it's amazing
quote we weren't sure if we were going
to give the department of justice
what we were going to give the
department of justice was going to be
used against us
and we weren't sure if there was going
to be an investigation
that is literally an admission of a
cover-up then you have layer 3
these allegations of bullying by again
democrats
a new york democrat and assemblyman ron
kim echoed by others and then layer four
just recently now this allegation of
sexual misconduct
by lindsey bohlen and this isn't an
allegation that comes from 40 years ago
when cuomo was in high school this is
something that happened relatively
recently
so as far as scandals go to use a
baseball term this one hits for the
cycle
but because there's a d next to governor
cuomo's name
he gets a pass here by most of the media
and particularly cnn and that d
by the way means disregard nothing to
see here
and that is a dereliction of duty sean
because this is absolutely a huge
national story what amazes me miranda
is okay the i believers right you have
the i believer caucus i believe i
believe i believe
okay i didn't say i took the position
that justice kavanaugh we need more
facts
he deserves the presumption of innocence
i believe in due process
and i'm taking the same position here
just because somebody says something
we don't have all the facts i don't
believe in rushing the judgment
the democrats are the ones that seem to
just use it when it's convenient
as a political story which should bother
people
absolutely and you know every man should
be given
the presumption of innocence uh when
these allegations come out every victim
should be heard
but we should keep a sense of proportion
but it doesn't work like that with the
democrats they use
feminism as a weapon it's not about
what's good for women
it's just about power yeah it's sad last
word joe
2018 julie swetnick comes out and
accuses brett kavanaugh of being a party
to gang rapes she's represented by
michael avenatti you know the serious
presidential contender who became like
the debate
captain at rikers at his cell block okay
so her allegations
are given no scrutiny nothing whatsoever
she even gets on national television
gets an
interview now in this case with lindsey
bohlen we can barely cover it so that's
all you need to know if you want to
compare
the way these two stories were covered
again because one was a conservative who
was being accused and now the other one
is a democrat and a prominent one joe
concha miranda devine thank you both